hair is made of long strands of a
protein called keratin some people have
hair follicles that produce keratin that
different rates across the hair these
people have curly hair to curl here the
keratin strands on the outside of each
hair are stretched and dried the bonds
reform with one side longer than the
other and you get curls high humidity
allows hair to reabsorb water and
straighten out again the shape that
curly hairs make is a helix a coil the
same as that found in the structure of
DNA there are equations which can
describe how the helix will look where x
y&z denote what's happening in each
direction R is the radius of the curl L
is the length of the curl and sine and
cos are relations from trigonometry if
we just look at the x-direction
it's a cosine wave like this and in the
y-direction we have a sine wave like
this these waves can be used to model
many different types of oscillating
cycles that occur throughout nature such
as sound waves visible light waves and
radio waves when we put it together with
another dimension zid letting the waves
move forward over a distance we get this
one complete curl is one cycle of the
wave the distance required to complete
one full cycle varies for every one if a
person's hair completes one full curl
cycle every ten centimeters then in 30
centimeters of hair there will be three
full curls but if they cut it short -
less than ten centimeters it would
appear straight or slightly wavy on the
other hand if someone had very curly
hair
a cycle every one centimeter then
cutting it short would not make it look
straight and it would be even bouncier
from the lack of weight